now we're up and running looking nice
welcome to our new host me open B shows
open assures this new podcast setup is
sold in Russia it's so romantic
welcome back to the gen Julian podcast
for those of you that are watching with
your eyes you'll notice that we've moved
locations for those of you listening
with your ears
welcome to the same podcast you've been
listening to well done thanks what an
intro that was perfect thanks that's why
she's my partner in this
it looks so romantic though we got our
chair set up where you know in her
living room now or not at the table
although we're just trying this out as
the location to see how it works yes we
are gonna experiment if we like it we
shall keep it if we don't we shall say
[ __ ] yeah cuz we still the table and
stuff so we can always go back there but
yeah we wanted to see what it was like
to sit in here in sit in chairs it's
nice I like it I mean I gotta say that
um having a comfy yeah I hope what you
doing right huh oh alright well
uploading the podcast now a little bit
about our lives we just got back from on
pretty crazy Vegas trip Vegas which was
a it was fun Jenna had an appearance at
the Ghostbar Dayclub at the Palms yeah
so it was a day club so there was
drinking in the day yeah it was wild it
was seriously so crazy because it [ __ ]
with your body to be at a club during
the day you mean yeah I think the music
was so loud
oh and we couldn't hear for like a whole
hour afterwards yeah no I mean I didn't
really like drink cuz she wants you
[ __ ] dude a drink you're [ __ ] yes
the night yeah we're sipped nicely but
yeah but I think I had like one
cranberry vodka over the course of the
two half hours or whatever and you know
after we left I felt [ __ ] up like just
you know you don't know where you are we
couldn't hear like it's just [ __ ]
that's so weird
it definitely throws you off I mean if
there's more than just alcohol it throws
your body off because you although the
way Rome explained
it was your body thinks that it's
partying like at a club because you are
at a club everything's like a club and
then you know there's still some like
daylight outside but once you let go and
do regular other daytime things your
body's like whoa [ __ ] yeah no that's
that's that's put really nice aiming up
and especially for people who we weren't
even drinking you know I mean like I
barely drink right yeah that's not like
we were hammered
yeah it's the way that the [ __ ]
remember we're talking about the
Venetian or whatever the casinos are
that paint them like daylight like when
rock clouds and it really like Fox with
your body so twisted yeah it's super
[ __ ] up they want you to have no
concept of time yeah if you want to
become a human lab rat just go to Vegas
and you will be completely [ __ ] with
and you won't even know it
oh yeah it's pretty wild yeah but it was
it was like it was super rowdy it was
super fun
and I've never seen anything like it
like what they were doing they had the
go-go dancers and stuff brought shopping
carts full of McDonald's cheeseburgers
out at one point
yeah they had beer bongs that people
were taking shots out of plastic
flamingos who's called Flo bongos it was
rowdy people were dressed up in costume
yeah a lot of people were in onesies it
was it was fun though you know we had
our own section so we weren't like
getting completely mashed the whole time
but Jenna hugged people for all two
hours yeah we just did hugs yeah uh it
was great I mean I I think it was one of
those things where it just kind of
really went smoothly which is always
nice yeah it was really nice um our
friend stopped by of course which was
nice also right he the production crew
except for Ryan he likes it you guys
meet up between a humming traveling for
Billy shows uh yeah but I want to go
back to finish his tattoo that's a dick
tattoo uh well and then we got home
hoping to have like a little relaxing
day and nope no we didn't know no
relaxing day oh yeah we haven't like
slept in at all for I want to say two
weeks like [ __ ] just up and Adam
packing and unpacking and moving and
finding places to live and waking up and
waiting for someone
oh my god just like such [ __ ] so I
was like after he went to Vegas which if
we had found a place that we can move
into before the 15th which we did like
this weekend would have been hell to
have moved in like on a Wednesday of all
days I think we're somewhere around
there and then just like peace out to
Vegas by Friday it's just miserable but
that wasn't the case but even still it
was like art the day after we drove back
all day yesterday and I was like that
Monday like I'm gonna [ __ ] just make
sure I get some good sleep you know not
schedule anything [ __ ] crazy for
today and it didn't even matter I
thought that I was gonna have the time
to unpack the rest of my clothes because
packing for Vegas was the worst because
I didn't want to [ __ ] any my [ __ ] was
you know miserable but then uh nope
ding-dong there's like people here
our landlord had called us at like 10:00
in the morning was like dis Jettas phone
even work I'm like dude dude is anyone
home I just don't we go there what's up
bro just like one day where didn't have
to wake up like eight [ __ ] hey I'm
just like sleep in a little bit come on
just a little just a little pay us a
little don't know maybe tomorrow no no
you got to work tomorrow no that sucks I
knows I have a [ __ ] a crazy week this
week I'll make them that Monday man I
want to just be in my pajamas and have
some coffee
all I know is hashtag rise & grind [ __ ]
you oh my god ding dong Jenna wake up oh
my god yeah parent Lee the balcony's
here there's like a balcony that had
previous water damage yeah so the
landlord and the people were like oh
yeah you know we might need a [ __ ]
fix it I'm like oh here we go here we
[ __ ] go like now I'm gonna be living
a construction zone warranting it
hopefully we won't we just got to keep
it positive and I don't know I just well
I suppose it was better than going out
there and then falling through yes that
is correct
ah it's weird though the way they
created those balconies wasn't the right
way to do it right they're higher or
hard and the house
house so it doesn't rain often but when
it does it will just pour into the house
yeah and of course there's no drainage
because they're on top like one of the
balconies is on top of another room in
the house right in order to drink so it
just on well it's on top of the office
yes so it will just go drip drip drip
drip all of our electronics everything
that can get fried by water will right
will get fried
that's Murphy's love fried
no that's Murphy's Law of Jena renting
apartments yeah anything that you
couldn't possibly imagine beforehand
that could go wrong with a property that
you're renting will go wrong if Jenna
writes her name on the lease it's gonna
be good we'll be okay yeah well if he
fixes it and then nothing gets broken
that sounds great
that's a great sign over that yes it's a
good possibility that that happens so
girl hey we shall wait what are you guys
up to what doing how about you done how
about you don't you do
mmm how you do man we just watched the
second episode of American Horror Story
which it's like I like this [ __ ]
season man dude
I'm getting a good feeling about the
season I'm not gonna lie like coven let
me down I well yeah I was obviously I
think in everyone's mind the weakest
part of the series because the first one
is scary
plus we had Connie Britton so I mean
you're anyone that's a fan of Friday
lights miss like I am my car's name is
Tim Riggins duh big Tim Riggins ever we
saw him we saw him at an airport flying
to Austin and I just could not on a
million years ever go up to him and even
say hi we were geeking out so hard so
hard but not being creepy we were just
so just to ourselves like squeezing each
other's hands like yeah were you like
walking to the gate and I spot him and
then I like didn't say anything am i
okay that's definitely him we sit down
like I don't know if he's facing this
way it's probably like his four o'clock
so weird like behind him and I'm like
Jenna calmly maybe just look up when you
have a second and look over there tell
me who you think that is and she looks
at Finch is like she looks down she like
looks back at me she's like that's big
tumor
yes it is died yeah I was really cool
and honestly I feel like gets it we'll
get back to American horse we're in
second but I felt like it was we we kept
it good you know I mean who knows what
would have happened if we went up and
said hi to him who no you might not
great he's such a nice guy yeah you
might have been great it probably would
have been great but we had that little
moment and we kept out of that because
if we I feel like we couldn't do
anything more we just had it yeah like
when people come up to me and say hi to
me like I always want to be like
rewarding of that because I know how
much it takes to like build up the
courage though we even say hi because I
can't do it yeah I mean that's a really
interesting point that I'm sure a lot of
people when they wonder like why you
were so nice to fans they wonder well
you know that's that's kind of her
thinking like it's not the easiest thing
to muster up the cards say I do it I
don't or someone you think is you know
just want to say hi I can't even say hi
I get way too scared yeah yeah I'm
impressed with some kids nowadays they
go for it dude when I was a kid I was
like nervous I there's nothing polite
though there yeah yeah absolutely always
polite but um yeah I've just never been
that way I've never been able to
approach people who were famous you know
I I think a couple bad experiences made
me never want to do it you know what I
mean like you say hi and you ask for
picture and you get denied you're like
what the [ __ ] just happened I can't
believe that went bad like in the back
of your mind you're like okay he always
could say no but it's never like oh he's
going to say no great so um no yeah that
with Tim Riggins week we had our moment
and we just kind of let it be a moment
and then we flew on the same flight as
him and we went it was like perfect that
we were going to Austin Texas to Michael
meet you and do it yeah we'll see you at
Dillon high no but I'm like that too
also with people that I like I really
really really like like for example my
car's name is [ __ ] baked Tim Riggins
like obviously I kind of loved him Rigas
Taylor Kitsch the actor but remember
when we're at the UFC fight and like my
love of all loves is George st. Pierre
and he's like someone asked him for a
picture names like yeah sure like a
couple rows in front of me and like
we're really close to where he was just
like walking by
and I just like I like froze I couldn't
move I couldn't speak and joy I was like
you gonna say hi to him like no no no
never never never because I don't I
don't even want to have a human
interaction with him I want to keep him
on a pedestal he's got to stay up there
and be talking and he's off that
pedestal right well yeah I just don't I
don't want a picture with him I don't
want to [ __ ] say anything to him I
just wanted quietly and privately read
out be in love with him I'm not five
that's really nice I remember when you
are guy and I looked at you and you were
just like don't do anything don't move
put it yeah it was like I just saw a
ghost yeah or like you know GSP yeah hey
he's really I mean he's like legendary
he's got this aura about him you see him
I mean I I saw him in 2011 when I was
grappling in Vegas for that convention
thing yeah and there was a bunch of
fighters there and I was leaving the
convention out like the parking lot and
I saw like it was like it was almost
like a mirage yeah but he walked out of
the door the back door of the Convention
Center surrounded by like three
bodyguards on each side and gets put in
this black SUV in that it were only it
was like two seconds you had to be there
right then and I was like uh no one was
there and I was like oh that was Jesus
pee yeah yeah just be like I hope no one
asks you know cuz they they won't
believe me but that was him
but yeah when we saw him that close it
made me feel like wow that's why I was
like that's like the Michael Jordan of I
mean you know that's not how I felt I
couldn't move my limbs I would say not
being able to move your limbs aligns a
little bit with Wow know you had a
special special moment so special um we
were talking about American Horror Story
which I do want to get back to yeah
anyways so the first season I felt like
for those of you that don't watch it or
haven't watched it this is obviously not
a promo for anything ever because our
podcast
once again sponsored by no one laughter
I know one we just like watching your
life here's our mid-roll el-ad sorry
sponsored by no one um but yeah the
first season of American Horror Story I
didn't want to watch at all because I'm
not a fan of horror because I get too
scared
I was like no like I know people really
like it but I really don't want to watch
it because I don't like scary stuff and
it was my trainer Jordan that convinced
me to [ __ ] watch he's like it's not
that scary it's just a really good show
and I was like all right maybe I'll
watch like an episode or two just to see
what it's like is it's a little creepy
but for those of you that are like me
that don't want to be scared ever
it's totally tolerable is that's fair
yeah for the most part I mean there's
some bloody stuff
yes I'm like cringy some creepy but yeah
they go there with like jumpy horrifying
like you're in a movie theater get me
the [ __ ] out it's almost like they're
bringing horror mainstream you don't
mean they're bringing order people who
can't stand horror yeah that's what I
mean because I've seen movies in the
movie theater where you know they have a
block of time that's like two and a half
hours or whatever to scare the [ __ ] out
of you so they really go balls to the
walls but they have a seasoned American
[ __ ] his entire season and now for
seasons to slowly build anticipation and
then scare you a little bit and then
scared a lot and then you know so it
makes it much more tolerable for someone
like me that can't handle all the
jumping scary like for example I thought
Jurassic Park was like the scariest
movie ever just to give you an idea of
what I'm terrified of dinosaurs if there
was an American Horror Story died but I
was convinced that a t-rex was gonna
come into my shower and bite me
well howdy Finn did you open the door
he's crashed right through the logistics
of it just don't matter I was just you
know Jolie just exactly wasn't even
attractive wasn't even in the movie just
when I was in my shower it was convinced
I was going down hey you know what all
you use an inkling that's what I always
says this isn't my intuition um but yeah
that it's totally tolerable the first
season is great it takes place in a the
house it's like a haunted house thing
and Dylan McDermott is in it anywhere is
no shirt a lot so if you're into that
you should
Dimon's dama dama why am i talking about
Tommy tournaments week join Illinois
I've never even watched that show have
you I don't know things you've ever seen
on what to call Cartoon Network adults
with adult Sonia and they go this week
removed every watch that's the voice
they used eyes like the voice over and I
think that's how the characters talk to
ya never seen you just want to [ __ ]
make that voice all the time yeah we
talk in that voice sometimes we got a
lot of work to do me this week like
Dylan McDermott I take my shirt off the
end oh man yeah the first season the
first seasons good cuz it's scary but at
the end of it was a little bit
ridiculous
yeah what's cool about that shows I went
into it just kind of knowing two things
one it's called American Horror Story so
you have to expect it to be a little bit
scary and the other thing is the posters
that you see for them create the viral
marketing yeah it's very creepy very
like shock value type stuff so those are
the two things I knew going into it
nothing else I had no idea what to
expect so the first season I loved I
thought it was like just the right
amount of scary you know and then the
second season was really good really
creepy and then 39 um asylum was great I
loved Asylum super weird and then the
third season I I had her really hot
helps for but yeah time asylum takes
place in the mental hospital and then
coven is a bunch of witches yeah
and that was the season they acquired
Kathy Bates Angela Bassett [ __ ] ash
Roberts Gabourey Sidibe like it sort of
had the ability to jump the shark
because they were getting all of these
celebrities yeah cast members you know
what I mean yeah but I think like that's
it wasn't [ __ ] scary like every week
I'm sort of like come on man like yeah I
don't know what you know Stevie Nicks
[ __ ] singing like enough songs bro I
came here for the storyline in the hole
they really lost what they were about
and their season and I felt frustrated
because not only did the show every week
not do it for me I felt like the cast
even like they're their characters were
just relaxed about things like they just
had this tone of like oh you know we're
we're in this coven house and well you
know what I'm gonna burn someone a
mistake or I don't know whatever you
know they just like didn't care and
you're like okay this is supposed to be
some life or death kind of craziest yeah
cuz like the other two seasons were and
they were just like hey whatever and it
made me feel that way so it was [ __ ]
Emma Roberts yeah you don't like her
yeah no no she's gonna read my personal
life read too much on the Internet yeah
it's like it's like you watch a movie
like Iron Man you like oh hey I like one
of Paltrow and then you read one thing
about her you're like oh [ __ ] I don't
like her anymore just a little bit
snobby yeah and the fact that we really
like Evan Peters and they were together
and all yes look yeah yeah um yeah I
feel bad for Evan Peters and all of the
drama that has since swarmed around yeah
and if you're curious about what we're
talking I just literally Google the two
names and you'll see all sorts of [ __ ]
huh but the positive the new season we
love it seems good well because I you
know I feel like that third season if I
was someone creating a television show
you're like me and like all these people
are saying yes they want to come be on
the show like it became more about like
how big can we make it by getting tons
of big-name celebrities like Cathy
[ __ ] Bates is it Angela Bassett at
her [ __ ] name or I just making that
up the african-american Buddha lady like
all day I only even know her is that cuz
you call her that I don't know I might
be getting her confused to somebody else
but like big actresses you know what I
mean just the Lang's already just like
[ __ ] in a legal yeah yeah yeah like
the third season they had built up
enough hype where they're they've become
like you know I don't a Seinfeld a
[ __ ] like where you can get any cameo
on the show yeah like this is easy next
thing yes yes yeah so I feel
they let that overpower you know this
season we get all these people being
like yeah sure and then II like well I
guess we got to write you apart and then
you know yeah and then the lost sight of
what this is sort of just got muddled
into like the [ __ ] am i watching in yeah
the [ __ ] am I actually watching but yeah
this seasons good it's promising it
seems to have said yeah it's nice and
[ __ ]
that's a Jenna said it's just the right
amount of [ __ ] yeah because it gets to
the point where I like when the
fucked-up [ __ ] happens it like makes you
happy on the inside cuz you're like yes
that's a good twist yeah yeah like today
what if if you were to sit down and
watch the first season like when I watch
the first season I was like oh my god we
could talk about that means boiler alert
we can talk about it right it happened
this last week the boy why don't you
talk about that twist that you really
love what we're allowed to talk about
it's not you know put a disclaimer water
spoilers you don't want to spoil it
although I don't know why we wouldn't
have seen the sex will just say spoiler
alert so if you're listening you just
pause it and fast forward well right the
time yeah well let you know but Jenna
what exactly about the season sorry this
week's last week's episode did you
really enjoy the twist
I don't know exact lands assistant oh oh
I like I like the like the rich kid that
was like oh I'm so bored with my like
magical gilded golden lifestyle that
like I need my mom to get me these like
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like he wanted to buy
the the double-headed Siamese twins and
she and they wouldn't they couldn't be
bought so then he tried to join that
[ __ ] circus man like this is my
calling I want to be in it they're like
no you can't you can't be here bro yeah
and so then he's like oh man who's this
[ __ ] crazy clown murderer can I be on
your team and he didn't even get that
you need to get the green light from him
oh he took it he just [ __ ] I'm just
gonna join you're so fun hey clown
I just love I love that like it's so
[ __ ] up the moment that you realize
like how he's just gonna jump [ __ ] yeah
murder people with the cloud yeah
like it makes you happy because you're
like yes like because it's like in the
back of your mind yeah yeah no I really
like that that was funny I did I
absolutely I told you after that scene I
was like okay I expected two things
happen and that was not one of them yet
it's dope but yeah that was really cool
um American Horror Story I'm excited
about that show
it'll be good season I think good noises
with your mouth
Thanks meep me Oh
meep for me why he need uh okay that
concludes our spawn accelerator said
yeah spoilers is done Megan here are
some mumble all right he'd need alright
be me what else have you been watching
Jillian on TV what if we uh Shark Tank
out uh what uh we watched Shark Tank I
love sharing fire rescue it was good
that was good last night I was get up so
I feel like they're getting to [ __ ]
like needy not needy is in manufacturing
drama yeah like they somebody threw a
firecracker behind the bar like producer
:
I know in the last one remember the girl
attacked the cameraman and it was like
alright guys we're not we're not getting
tired of bad bars turning into good bars
just leave it at that yeah I I don't
need anything else to keep me watching
or to suck me in or anything like that I
I'm willing to watch the show if you
just do bar innovation just do bar own
emissions and have Jon Taffer yell at
some guy I'm yeah you put your shoes up
in you show me some delicious cocktails
in the process and you tell people how
much they suck at their current job yes
you give them new jobs yes like their
old job except the way done recipe yeah
yeah yeah we like that I don't know
please don't change that bar rescue
right soon it is I sent in yeah I still
enjoy it cuz I still like bar rescue
no matter what but um yeah be nice if
they started to focus back on rescuing
bars and less on shenanigans
shenanigans seaons what else we watching
watching to catch a contractor has
really goofy it's really goofy but um so
it's Adam Carolla and his buddy skip
so then Skip's wife is supposedly a
private detective private investigator
private investigator
okay all she does is make phone calls
and then gets out this camera with this
gigantic zoom and pretends to zoom in on
them like I would love to know if that
[ __ ] is really a private investigator I
doubt it I have a driver's license and
my phone has a camera on it can I be a
private investigator too it's such a
joke you so much like yeah I'm gonna get
this guy Omega know his phone number and
I'm gonna go find him buddy here let me
let's explain how bad of a private
investigator she is on the second season
she has to have someone go with her
because she's being seen too much isn't
a private investigator supposed to be
invisible you're not supposed to know
you so why do you need another face in
case you'll get recognized what a joke
dude I don't know that's that's the
least believable aspect yeah but Adam
Crowe is funny and the premise of the
show is get they do a good job of like
well first of all they do a good job
with the confrontation they love that
[ __ ] yeah but then the actual
renovations of the house is really nice
to watch especially because that you see
how [ __ ] the people got by that
contractor and then they get it back
which is nice it's a feel-good show move
that bus good Sophie good move that bus
that bus move that bus I really said
boss oh I was really sad when that stop
getting me yeah because that drug you me
all the fields yeah I watched that when
I was a kid too it was a little
ridiculous though right yeah they
couldn't like it was like pimp my ride
they like victimized yeah I know but
remember how Rome always says like a
really nice house sound like a weird
streets just king of the [ __ ] a new
addiction that you never want to live in
king of the [ __ ] yeah I love this
with that huh yeah can you imagine like
some of them they they made over were in
these like seriously underprivileged
neighborhoods and then they would just
build these people like a [ __ ]
mansion just to get right property line
up
yeah and then all of your neighbors are
like look pal
you're either going to invite us over we
gonna throw [ __ ] bricks through
window yeah you know what I mean and I'd
be pissed off if somebody got a free
[ __ ] house across the street from me
wouldn't you yes but I wouldn't throw
bricks through my job but I hear what
you're saying because like fine I get to
come Belize in your movie theater
because they built you a movie theater
it is a little bit of a loophole then a
problem with that idea of building big
houses and some shitty areas but no
hopefully no one got to her good Keisha
that's all I do now but I like that show
it was a good show yeah it was a good
show but can you imagine doing that you
know more than a year and you build a
house in seven days like how [ __ ]
that is like no matter how many people
they had they were always just like you
could tell the stress level was that
like a 50 Oh
people were cracking the whip on
everyone and no fun yeah just not really
that possible
no but maybe that's why the ship stopped
yeah the whole house probably just
smelled like [ __ ] wet paint and like
construction yeah well yeah I don't know
I mean how do they even do the
foundation child labor no it's not a
matter of labor it's a matter of like
time and yeah they need to like try yeah
yeah no they had yeah no I don't know
how they did it
cheating hmm how do we know with seven
days was there any very good yeah yeah
but they said it but what if it wasn't
and they said it wasn't well I guess
we'll never know
coz it's off the air now hair air hair
um I started listening to a podcast
recently it's a weightlifting podcast
but it's interesting at listen to the
podcast I haven't listened to a podcast
that's so long I think my freshmen or
sophomore year of high college was the
last time I listened to a podcast and
then I went all that time without
listening to it and then I started one
here so it's interesting in here a
podcast and I definitely hear what you
guys say when you you know
no esse in the car and do your homework
and other stuff like that because it I
love hearing the conversation you know
even if you disagree with certain people
or whatever it's very comforting to kind
of sit there and let let people talk
yeah it's nice just kind of an anecdotal
thing you don't have to respond about it
I just want to say that no I mean I've
listened to a bunch of vodcast
night I don't regularly listen to
podcasts but if there's something that I
want to hear that I know is going on
I'll [ __ ] listen to it and it's really
nice especially when you're a fan of
like the guest or somebody in the show
because it's like maybe grace or like
Tyler like other chain like other
youtubers that have podcasts like I
would I would want to sit down and
listen to that but for the most part
like the people to have really great
guests are sort of people were like I
could sort of take or leave your your
podcast just yeah but then I'll tune in
for sure if it's somebody I really want
to listen yeah I listen to TJ Miller was
a guest on someone else's podcast so I
think he podcast regularly just like the
stuff that [ __ ] comes out of his
mouth just like gives me the giggle dick
yeah he's so fine he hits me right in
the giggle deck hits us hands me half of
it is his accent that like Long Island
not so long I'm sorry it's like a
Wisconsin like other you knows Michigan
sort of northern AMERICA AMERICA accent
yeah what did I that movie she's not
that Indio she that movie you him in
that movie made guys die your kiss is on
my list god she crushes that movie as
the alike bitter best friend because
your kiss is all my list
oh yeah I brought the good news bear
somebody get her some [ __ ] honey
that's not the rely on movie all right
huh why what podcast you listen to uh
weightlifting one yeah because I listen
in the car on the way back or Diggins
listen to the ones Martin - eat your
cloak up clothes off sorry why what is
wrong with my like mouth diarrhea bring
our stuff they're both named Dmitri no
it's not tough at all
riddle me a time when I would ever read
you're right it's been a long day sorry
guys like a super long dmitriy klokov
was on barbell shrugs that's the name of
the podcast I was new and I picked that
episode to share Jenna with you know he
let her listen to also because I know
she loves Dmitri is it was extra special
because he doesn't know how to speak
English that well so he says things that
are hilarious yeah and Mike everything
was that like he rarely had things
translated which was very impressive
like seven months of grayish blob but
well my favorite thing was like when
they would ask him a question and then
even answer but very simply but there's
like a long pause and he's like yes and
then it's just like so what I mean like
because he had to think about it and
then he gives a straight-up answer yeah
okay I was perfect that's awesome but
you know I loved hearing what he was
saying he was talking you know about
training about the differences in
weightlifting in Russia and the US and
and what his life is like it because he
tours the world non-stop doing seminars
that's literally his job like that's
what he does and he's supposedly you
know gonna have to start training in
what like April for the not April of to
15 hour 2015 for the Rio Olympic Games
in 2016 I mean the guy he's like 31 and
he's doing a million things but he's so
great for the sport which is know he's
was really popular he does a good job
but that was really fun podcast to
listen to it's always interesting
digging my world who's digging on the
couch I just like when he can't he would
say something that would just make me
laugh because he's saying it correctly
with the way that he says it it sounds
funny yeah so he you know I forget what
he's saying he felt something for his
daughter and he was like yes and then I
said this for you my my daughter
that's a baby that's my little baby does
yeah
miletto Dada you're like oh my god
[ __ ] getting legs yeah
dmitriy klokov is an epic man he's an
epic man I'm not like I'm not ever gonna
say like little daughter like that ever
again I don't like that
hello they said here you go my little
daughter I read my letter I don't know
something about the way Russians speak
everything just sounds so epic a
tornado's Russian and I was like I was
gonna ask my good man yeah he was
Russian well I just said hi to him in
Russian you know how to say hi and
goodbye forget home you never remember
no um give me the first syllable of it
of what of hi yeah it's righteously no
uh Stratos nope uh give me the second
syllable come on um it's Rocky's way
frothy trotty's way it's a little bitter
it's draw sweetie a raw sweet thick I
was close it's raw sweet eh all right
give me the first hello goodbye
das da svidaniya yeah you did it right
what's the first oboe of the other one I
love you what was the last thing you saw
the last thing you taught me I don't I'm
not sure I know I love you but I say I
love and then something did I learn that
no let's give it a shot give me the
first syllable yeah yeah Oh seconds a
little no I'm not gonna do this um yes
we Don Bellini that L sorry I'm sorry
I don't know Russian da svidaniya good
bye good Russian stressful day and you
say [ __ ] to be as abou [ __ ] to be as
abou that means what's your name doctor
Vyasa who actively as a food Julien
doctor beelzaboot no you say okay that
works
and it's a very cloak of hi what's your
name
Dimitri's what's your name
oh that's good I know the Russian no you
say what my name is Julian
so say many Azabu Julian many as aboot
Julia yeah that's me Dania no no way to
say I love something as you say yeah
you've you just like I love Putin I only
said that because when I was in high
school we had to make a pretend City and
like label everything like the library -
yes of like that so I made Putin grad
because I had seen this picture of Putin
looking very nice way like takes his
shirt off and goes fishing and [ __ ] so I
was like yeah Putin and my teacher
thought it was the most hilarious thing
ever obviously because it's Vladimir
Putin yeah but I was like nah man I know
what I'm doing it's called [ __ ] Putin
grad [ __ ]
so I just cut out the stain like sexy
picture of him and put it on like the
library in the school I was [ __ ]
amazing interstate roll I know I was
trying so hard and my teacher [ __ ]
loved it that's awesome yeah but yeah
that was Putin Grod Putin Grande and
she's like it's funny because it's
basically a spoon grad anyways Touche
that's really good a little Jana was a
troll I wasn't even that little I was
like 17 16 lil mm-hmm young Jenna
painted driver's licenses younger Jenna
no driver's license Jenna was a troll
yeah I feel like I've been like an adult
in my brain since I was like yeah like
12 or 13 how old were you when you were
like this is my brain oh [ __ ] um we're
so using what ages I feel like I was an
adult
yeah um probably yeah driver's license
is a solid moment that you start feeling
like an adult because you don't want to
need someone to drive with and that's a
big thing you know ya know I mean ever
anywhere I guess I'm not talking about
like when you felt like responsibility
wise you were an adult I'm saying
consciously like in you
mentally in your own brain Oh went like
when did you start being the exact
person that you always have been knew I
mean that's good question yeah yeah you
know what I feel I feel like it came
after high school yeah I mean like cuz
in high school I feel like in high
school you just are so caught up in all
sorts of [ __ ] that isn't real and then
when you leave high school you realize
how fake everything is and how there's
the life is that oh it's like a
helicopter you can hear throughout wall
that's crazy oh these mics are really
good they're good they pick up on the
helicopters hating they're good I'm good
I think it was in college cuz I doubt I
dealt with having to stop playing
baseball and having to realize that like
okay I got a really kind of be an adult
now and everything in my that I really
thought about all the time was circling
around baseball for a while and now I'm
gonna have to start functioning like an
adult that doesn't involve that I think
that's safe to say
you know freshman sophomore year of
college but I wasn't a dummy for the
time before that I'm you know I knew
things I was self-sufficient in my brain
I was I say no no I'm sick when I was
like 12 or 13 I sort of just was like
it's snapped one day that was like I
still have all those same personality
traits like the same morals the same
like everything journey mean like I'm no
longer a child I am now cognizant in my
own brains like this is my brain this is
who I am it's very impressive like a
sense of identity huh and then you know
you pick up malls as you live on and
when you change as a person you know
what I mean like obviously when I was 12
or 13 if someone wrote a note that said
your name and then said something mean
about it you'd go cry in the bathroom
like not everything about you stays a
constant I'm just saying that's when I
like sort of woke up and I feel like in
my brain I've always been that same
person does that make sense no that
makes perfect sound yeah yeah I know
you know I think parts I'm you know
parts of my personality we're developed
at really young ages and parts of how I
think we're developed younger but not
all of it you know what I mean yeah but
no that's that's impressive and that's
interesting to think about when you
think back but like I know I remember
this time but yeah when do you say that
do people listening and watching when
did you start being the person that you
are in your own brain if that makes any
sense at all yeah it's a hard concept to
grasp onto it is but it's very
interesting to think about cuz you just
I feel like you you have just started
like a little bit of a moment of clarity
where you're just like oh this is who I
am this is what I'm yeah yeah that's
interesting anything but I'm still
pondering pondering way what could it be
oh it's a tamper what the foam I god
he's referring to the I dare you video
that we did with Ryan Higa and
yeah they blindfolded me and they put
something in my mouth and it was a
tampon and I was like so flustered yeah
you're like put it in my mouth again
could be could it be you know plastic on
the outside and then it's like soft on
the inside I don't know
it's a damn fun I think you said the
words unused dancing is it an unused
temple well because I I I really didn't
want to use tampons off and I also had
asked if there was poop in my mouth
earlier there was no book man only had
ass that was fun who in the [ __ ] would
do that to their friend with blindfold
them do like I don't know but stuff in
your mouth think I'm just gonna put some
[ __ ] in your mouth like what kind of
people do you think we are I don't mean
to sell you guys okay guys had to ask
right you know what when you're
blindfolded you start to question things
man no like that even just the killer
karaoke episode like when she was
feeling things from the boxes and
yes and it was literally that's exactly
there and she was screaming your [ __ ]
head off to paint a picture it's called
killer karaoke is a game show hosted by
Steve oh wow it's not yes I don't think
it's on yeah they blindfolded this woman
and they had to stick her hand in these
tanks with random objects in it and what
Genna was talking about was when there
was just a teddy bear in it because
she's blindfolded her imagination makes
that teddy bear the nastiest freakiest
thing ever
she can't even handle in her defense
like one of them was like a skunk and
she was watching up [ __ ] head up and it
was like pigeons yeah no they didn't
they mess with you pretty good but well
just kept touching the timer good I love
when they have to sing that's that's
really good um they have to sing the
whole time yeah no but some of them just
like give up I love when like they
really stick with the same part there
was one woman who was like I think it
might have been her who's just like
crushing no the best one was I made a
video after it was like getting zapped
and singing at the same time this guy
was getting [ __ ] electric shock he
was a waiter while he was being a waiter
and he was getting shocked so hard that
he was dropping the things he was
supposed to be bringing back and forth
to steve-o and never and singing and he
really crushed it and I was so impressed
he had him like on his arms and legs
like everywhere so torturous getting
[ __ ] lit up yeah he's very impressive
yeah that's uh I understand why you're
scared yeah remember the sensation of
even-even every time killer is in front
of it yeah being your troll son nitrile
I charge a sheet Rosa I job good otter
face lovely next week we won't be
putting this up so late we just had a
crazy weekend and a crazy Monday and we
really have any [ __ ] time at all and
then uh you know last minute the toilet
just started [ __ ] if we didn't notice
we came genican Dawson's but if we
didn't notice it would have flooded
probably the whole floor on the first
yeah I went to go put a suitcase but for
the record no doing of our own could
work I went to put a suitcase in the
other room
and [ __ ] there was just water
spilling out of the bathroom I'm like no
not again like oh my god
so I called a plumber and he came and it
was just like the thing that you flush
it and then it goes up it's called an
offer and then it goes like that it had
like completely worn down on the inside
of the toilet so he just fix the plastic
garden it was like really thank you
because last time this happened it was a
[ __ ] ordeal no I was in such a
sigh of relief when it was fixed with
one simple he was in and out of here in
like 20 minutes
and he fixed the washer which the people
that installed the washer didn't screw
on the hook up like this again you shut
a water bottle and you don't screw it
right so it's like leaks yeah that's how
we install the washer washer so I
started like dripping water I'm like no
why can't I just ever live somewhere
this is it once the Russian plumber left
we got 10 times happier because we hit a
lot yeah cuz we were like can you please
take a look at the washer too since
you're here he goes yeah oh it's just
okay sir I'm like muy just make sure
when you use the bathroom you clean up
that water and then you're good to go
like to you the man dude man we kept his
card yeah we needs to say but I'll say
it anyway right yeah I'll call him
anytime anything breaks and he's based
right here where we live so that's so
great okay like do you do you fix
people's like brains can you face me cuz
I'm losing mine do you have fun do you
wanna be my friend do you wanna hang out
20 limo this week on fixing toilets with
online mmhmm yeah next week hopefully
our podcast will be up in a little bit
less yes sir you should have it up by
Monday morning early this is the first
cup podcast we did in this house though
right this is our first podcast in the
new house I know I'm still stressed out
because everything's crazy but this
podcast is way less stressful than like
the last couple we did yeah like very
intense last couple both of them were
very
we were in the midst of a [ __ ] oh we
were going [ __ ] through it man but we
did it and we did it for you and we did
it and we're proud and we are now in the
new house all set up I talked for me and
you and you but me is in there too so
that if you said you did it for you
early give a little more marbles what
about my feelings
what about PG well I did fall did you
all of them did you do it for CJ cool
Julianne yeah clearly difficult you go
work
thanks for the pet yeah I'll Pat you
I'll pay you go pack go pack thank you
well makes me feel good
thanks for watching guys thanks for
watching Jen Julianne podcast if you
liked this setup let us know by typing
in the number 14 to the comments to see
I like to set up a microphone and then
if we get enough for teens who stay
otherwise we could do a thing called um
we just setup with musical podcast
chairs musical chair podcast shared um
thank you again for watching uh we will
be earlier next week hopefully and yes
please do give us your thoughts on the
new setup and also give us your thoughts
and everything we talked about because
part of this thing is hearing what so
that okay Harry Potter music okay anyway
please participate in the conversation
in the comments tweet at us follow us we
will be back next week the outro music
run all the things
that's not our outro music it is thank
you guys we love you I've even got the
best part
I'll let it run
we're rolling the credits we're done
thank you all right see you guys you can
really stop okay I'm done